I means lay your heart I'm Bret Baier
I'm Katie Pavlich and this is the Fox
News rundown
Friday April 3rd 2020 I'm Chris Foster
the corona virus pandemic isn't just a
challenge in the civilian world our
military plans for just about every
eventualities and I'm sure they've
they've planned for this one as well i'm
lisa brady this is a time of high
anxiety for everyone and some have a
harder time coping with it we're worried
about getting the virus we're worried
about the economy we're worried about
our jobs worried about our families but
for those who have mental illnesses
those worries can become all-consuming
and I'm Jimmy Fallon I've got the final
word on the Fox News rundown
[Music]
the military has a role to play dealing
with the corona virus pandemic the Army
Corps of Engineers putting up makeshift
hospitals there are hospital ships in
New York and Los Angeles the National
Guard is deployed in all 50 states
helping with duties like drive-through
testing this infections traffic checks
and deliveries National Security Advisor
Robert O'Brien says the virus will not
distract from national security and
warns anyone looking to take advantage
of the crisis let me be clear it would
be a mistake a mistake with terrible
consequences for any adversary to
attempt to do us harm during this health
crisis or ever for that matter hundreds
of troops are infected with Koba tonight
team of cases tripling in the last week
with these additional challenges how do
you protect the homeland there's no
question I can tell you that our
military our intelligence community is
entirely focused as they always have
been on those threats to our national
security of Dan Hoffman's of Fox News
contributor and retired CIA station
chief whether it's Iran or North Korea
or Afghanistan terrorism proliferation
cyber hacking look that these threats
are ongoing and the work goes on in
spite of of the challenges we face and
from the coronavirus it may be some
changes we need to make in terms of how
we're doing our mission certainly for
the military but the work goes on for
sure yeah I mean the military is gonna
have to adapt their close quarters in a
lot of cases how do you practice social
distancing how do you how does it impact
training right so let's draw a
distinction between social distancing
and physical distancing so what we're
doing is is staying away from each other
five six feet away from each other but
the social part is ongoing in fact it's
even more intense than it's arguably
ever been whether you're talking about
the intelligence community or the US
military so yeah absolutely
training formations where you've got
people you know close close together
chow halls there's all sorts of new
rules and regulations that I'm sure the
military is implementing to try to limit
the spread of the corona virus we've
already seen with the Theodore Roosevelt
air carrier that it's hard to do that
and this is going to be a challenge for
us but our military plans
just about every eventualities and I'm
sure they've they've planned for this
one as well
thousands of sailors are taken off the
USS Teddy Roosevelt aircraft carrier
with dozens testing positive for covin
19 acting Navy secretary Thomas motely
the situation is very dynamic and we are
supporting our subordinate commanders to
ensure we protect our sailors and our
Marines so that they can protect the
homeland and maintain their readiness to
the best of our ability the Teddy
Roosevelt's docked in Guam there could
end up being outbreaks on other ships as
well to get back to your to your early
question you know will bad actors try to
take advantage of what they might
perceive to be a decrease in u.s.
readiness even though our readiness
hasn't decreased so might China which
has been militarizing the South China
Sea take more aggressive action we've
already seen North Korea launch missiles
in in in recent weeks so the United
States military needs to maintain that
level of readiness for sure it's going
to be a challenge and it's why the
physical distancing is so important
taking every precaution that you can
isolating those who are testing positive
I think what the military is doing and
in some ways it's a microcosm of what
we're doing writ large and our nation is
testing their people determining who
might be carriers of the virus and then
ensuring that those folks are
quarantined to limit the spread right
and find out who may have already been
infected and once we can determine if
reinfection is isn't very likely then if
we can get those guys back to work now
the Pentagon has told installations stop
reporting your cases I guess it's just a
sign you don't want people to use that
that intelligence of how many people you
have at an installation and how many
people are now lost yeah I mean look we
just don't need to be advertising to the
world the number of our servicemen and
women who are who have been infected
with the corona virus that that isn't
anything we need to be doing I would
highlight too at the same time that
that's a collection requirement for our
intelligence community look the Chinese
have been vastly under reporting the
severity of the corona virus and the
number of Chinese who have been infected
by it the North Koreans are claiming
that they have zero
cases so how many cases there are in
those countries what steps they're
taking and then geopolitically what is
the impact on these countries Iran China
North Korea they are brittle autocracies
and the people in those countries are
for sure very concerned about the the
number of the cases of the corona virus
and the fact that their governments
haven't taken the proper steps to
protect them in the first place and then
to treat them in the second case that
could have impacts on the stability of
these governments to use the do you if
you gain this out in your head do you
see any possible uprisings in some of
these more brittle governments if you
want to call in governments yeah I mean
I I've likened the coronavirus to she
shout pings Chernobyl you know we saw
some of the same you know some of the
same things with with Xiaoping as we saw
with the Soviets in 1986 a obsequious
bureaucrats who were afraid of telling
the truth to the leadership a failure to
make proper decisions quickly to prevent
this you know or to mitigate a disaster
I mean the Chinese didn't take any steps
that they should have taken when they
first learned of the virus outbreak and
put their citizens at risk as a result
now look the there won't be a
coronavirus Commission in China at least
not a formal one but there is one on the
streets and same thing in Iran where the
Iranians were allowing flights to and
from China and took none of the steps
that they should have taken to protect
their people you can add that to the
long list of grievances that the
Iranians have had that have resulted in
protests last year's quite significant
ones and I think that that one of the
reactions we're going to be looking for
once the physical distancing period is
over whenever that may happen is that
people may take to the streets
protesting the brutal Iranian
dictatorship and what it's meant for the
health of the population then real quick
back to our military we know that some
hospitals municipalities have complained
that they're low on supplies how
prepared is the military as far as
protective equipment and are they going
to get first dibs on stuff like that and
tests yeah I think that one of the
things about our militaries that they
try to be self-sufficient almost
operating separately entirely from
what we're doing in in the private
sector so they would be having their own
you know PPE their own hospitals trying
to take care of themselves as they need
to and and I'm sure that you know months
ago look we've known about the potential
for this and how it could impact us
overseas for months going back to when
the virus first broke in in Wuhan we
first learned about it and our
intelligence community reportedly had
information about it so the military
would have would have known that and
would have been preparing because they
deploy overseas even if we thought the
virus night might not have made its way
to the United States our military would
have been preparing for the possibility
that they might have had to face it in
the South China Sea or wherever they
were overseas so you know this is what
the military does they've got a plan on
the shelf for just about everything and
I have confidence that they're managing
it extremely well albeit you know given
the challenges that we face Fox News
contributor Daniel n Hoffman Dan thanks
for coming on the podcast a always a
pleasure
[Music]
this is Jimmy fella with your Fox News
commentary coming up for most of the US
and many other parts of the world
staying at home is the new normal and it
doesn't feel normal at all the whirlwind
of closures cancellations and shortages
and the staggering economic toll all as
the awful count of Kovac 19 cases and
deaths continues we're never going to be
the same again we're not going to forget
what happened here the fear that we have
the anxiety that we have that's not just
going to go away New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo during one of his daily
briefings this week saying he doesn't
think will get back to the same normal
as before but people keep finding new
ways to make the best of it and help
each other don't get too much cabin
fever be safe
hold on to you and your loved ones and
we'll make it through this one day at a
time that's one of the former students
Tennessee high school teacher Drew van
Huss reached out to posting videos
online hoping to help alleviate stress
by sharing stories but there are things
we can all do to help ourselves and our
families adjust first and foremost you
need to do things that are aimed at
taking care of yourself dr. Joshua
Gordon is director of the National
Institute for mental health so for many
of us we're staying on top of the news
we're trying to understand what's going
on and that's great but you also need to
take breaks from the news set aside
periods of time each day when you turn
off your social media feed you turn to a
program on the television or on Netflix
that's all about something fun something
to enjoy that's number one number two
take care of your body make sure that
you eat regular well-balanced meals get
some physical activity try to avoid
using alcohol or drugs especially if
you're using to escape that's that's not
as helpful as one might think and
importantly give yourself a full night
sleep another really important factor
especially since
were all physically isolated or not all
of us across America but most of us take
some time to connect with others talk
with people that you trust about your
concerns about how you're feeling but
also just about the everyday and it's
fortunate that in this day and age we
have lots of digital tools that we can
use to help so it's not just about the
telephone
it's about texting it's about zoom
conferences it's about FaceTime it's
about all the different tools that we
have to see each other face to face even
if we can't do it physically that can be
really important again to help preserve
your mental well-being now if you do
have anxiety issues for instance along
with other issues that could come into
play this can really be a nightmare
scenario because all of a sudden you
feel like you have a lot more things to
worry about yeah for most of us now
we're worried right we're worried about
getting the virus we're worried about
the economy we're worried about our jobs
worried about our families but for those
who have mental illnesses those worries
can become all-consuming if we're all
feeling a little suspicious about people
around us for those of us with
schizophrenia or other mental illnesses
that suspiciousness can turn into
paranoia and it can really disrupt our
lives so for those people who have
mental illnesses who already know that
they have a predisposition towards
anxiety depression or other mental
illnesses it's really important that
they also do their best to take care of
themselves that means calling your
mental health provider in advance and
making arrangements for telehealth
visits that means laying in a supply of
medication if you're taking medication
for your condition to make sure that you
can make it through the next month or
two with adequate doses of your
medicines that means reaching out to
your normal social supports and letting
them know that this is a hard time for
you whether those be you know groups
pure groups or whether those be friends
or loved ones reach out to them let them
know that you need a little extra
attention we're all trying to reach out
to the people we care about we want to
help you so make that effort and and and
that's one way that you can stay well
what about the strain on relationships
how do we deal with that when it arises
because it almost invariably will I mean
some couples may sort of be at each
other's throats and it's difficult to
suddenly have the kids in the house all
the time instead of some of the time
especially depending on their ages
you're all kind of lumped together now
and you really can't escape each other
very well
I mean togetherness can be great too but
it may not be enough to just say let's
try to focus on the positive so how do
you deal with that strain on family
relationships what's the best way you
are right this is hard and the first
thing is acknowledge it's hard talk to
your kids talk to your spouse talk to
your partner your parents whoever's in
the home with you and say look I know
this is hard
second piece is try to be flexible try
to tolerate some deviations from what
you would normally tolerate try to
recognize that in in in living in the
same space you're gonna have to give and
take and the more that you can give the
more that other people can let you take
at other times so try to be flexible the
third piece is when you do run into
trouble talk about it recognize that hey
the reason we're on each other's nerves
is because we're on on top of each other
let's let's talk through this let's
figure out ways that we can try to avoid
triggering each other
let's find different spaces in the home
even if it's just different sides of a
room that we can work in let's try to
get together and talk about the things
that were arguing about let's try to set
up times that we focus on the kids and
other times where you focus on each
other or focus on work
try to set up structures that minimize
that conflict so that all that stuff is
really important what are some ways to
make all this easier on children
that kind of parallel the
recommendations for adults I know I've
heard that the structure of the remote
learning for those that are able to do
remote learning at home that structure
to their day is one big piece of it but
are there other ways you know besides
sticking just somewhat of a normal
schedule that it's that there are ways
to make it easier for kids well
certainly structure is important right
try to have them get up at the same time
you eat their meals at the regular times
provide them with activities throughout
the day that's that's important I think
another important fact that's often
overlooked is that the children in
addition to just wanting to be with
their classmates and playmates and
wanting to engage and do things that are
fun they are also anxious they are also
going through this with us so take some
time to talk about what's going on with
them but don't expect that they have the
same anxieties that you do you might be
concerned about getting the virus you
might be concerned about the economic
situation or your job but your kids
might be concerned about the fact that
you know what their best friend's
birthday is next week and they're not
going to be able to be there so if you
take some time to find out what's going
on with them then you can better address
it oh we can set up a zoom birthday
party for your friend right so listen to
your kids answer their questions and
that will help reduce their their
concerns their anxieties about what's
going on I wanted to ask you too about
the people on the front lines of this
the whole range of health care workers
first responders scientists to I mean it
just seems like so much constant
pressure and risk for them what do you
tell them first thing I tell health care
providers when I talk to them and i am
talking to them the first thing I tell
them is thank you we owe a huge debt of
gratitude to our frontline workers be
the healthcare providers be their police
or fire or paramedics
home health attendants even the cleaning
people in nursing homes and hospitals
think about all the people that are out
there working from you know every angle
of the situation who are out there
facing risk every day to help take care
of people who need to be taken care of
second thing I say is the same sorts of
things that I tell everyone which is
they're also dealing with the kovat 19
epidemic from a personal and a family
perspective so take some time and allow
yourself to relax to do what you need to
do to take care of yourself because if
you can't take care of yourself you're
not going to be take you able to take
care of others any closing thoughts for
anyone listening who might really be
starting to feel the strain of all the
social distancing and the cabin fever
and everything that goes with this
because there's really no denying that
the longer this goes on the harder it
gets I would I would say two things
number one this will not last forever we
don't know how long it will last but we
will get through it to the other side
the the second thing I would say is that
it is working there is enough evidence
out there that the social distancing
that we are all engaging in is starting
to have an effect in terms of reducing
the impact of the pandemic so we are all
heroes we are all doing something to
prevent the worst impact
this epidemic just by staying home just
by being in our homes focusing on our
families we are all doing our part
dr. Joshua Gordon director of the
National Institute of Mental Health
thanks so much for your time thanks I
appreciate the opportunity and stay well
from the Fox News podcasts Network
download and listen to the media buzz
meter with Howard Kurtz how he picks
five stories most important to the most
entertaining to the buzziest subscribed
and listen now by going to fox news
podcast comm america's listening to fox
news subscribe to this podcast at fox
news podcasts comm and now some good
news with tonya j powers
[Music]
[Applause]
so you can hear the noise outside I'm
standing in Manhattan outside my
building and people for several nights
now it's a nightly thing at seven
o'clock this is what you hear you hear
people yelling and cheering and it's
like an alarm goes off at 7:00 p.m.
Eastern and people come out of their
windows and this is what they do they
cheer for the medical community one guy
has a some sort of mixing bowl maybe
stainless steel some kind of pan or pot
there and he's beating on it there are
folks with cowbells
there are people just cheering clapping
lots and lots of clapping another round
of cheers there and even honking I don't
know if you guys can hear that up in the
background but there's honking and this
is what people do at seven o'clock in
New York City and the NYPD gets involved
they're showing their support as well as
the officer drives a cruiser past
wearing a mask
and it goes on for several minutes every
night at seven o'clock these are the
sounds of New York that aren't sirens
and it's a welcome thing honestly
these days this is what good news sounds
like in New York City
[Music]
tanja joy powers FoxNews it's time for
your fox news commentary me fail up
what's on your mind
so the Federal Trade Commission has
logged over 7,000 complaints of people
selling fraudulent cures to the
coronavirus these scams have netted 4.7
million dollars and I don't know what's
scarier that people allow themselves to
be this evil or that the people who fell
for it are allowed to vote
folks I've been covering politics for
ten years so I am well aware that there
are some silky smooth talking con men
out there but I don't care what someone
tells you in a spam email or an official
press release from a Nigerian prince
which are one of the same the only place
you can buy the cure is on iTunes and no
I'm not talking about medicine I'm
talking about an 80s new wave band if
you try to buy The Cure anywhere else
you'll be singing Friday I'm in debt
because the only thing getting healthy
is some crooks bank account and you
might get your identity stolen along the
way because most of these are phishing
scams although in fairness the last time
my identity got stolen my credit score
went up 12 points
so thanks Ukrainian hackers look folks I
get that it's a crazy time but if we're
gonna beat this thing we need to start
playing smart ball follow the CDC social
distancing guidelines and stay home is
it really that big a deal your
grandparents were asked to go to war for
this country you're being asked to sit
on the couch and watch Netflix you're
not being asked to save Private Ryan
you're being asked to watch Private Ryan
I think you can handle it and while
you're cruising social media on the
couch use some common sense when it
comes to medical advice if the guy
offering you health tips has a neck
tattoo in his profile picture chances
are he didn't study corona
he drank Corona and when life gives you
lemons you can't use them to cure a
virus so stick them in your beer and
move on if you need medical information
watch the daily briefings from the White
House the president bragged the other
day that the ratings are higher than the
finale of The Bachelor and they also
last longer than the couples on The
Bachelor so they've got that going for
them too dr. Anthony Falchi has become
so popular he was just honored with his
very own bobblehead doll yeah it shakes
its head whenever
president talks I'm kidding but I'm dead
serious when I tell you that we need to
flatten the curve on stupidity before it
flattens our bank accounts we're gonna
need that money to join a gym when this
is over because we've all been eating
like a sumo wrestler on his cheat day
gotta run Pizza guys here check out Fox
News radio with Jimmy fellow weekdays
from noon to 3 on Fox News radio and Fox
News Radio dot-com
you've been listening to the Fox News
rundown and stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at Fox News
podcasts calm and for up-to-the-minute
news go to Fox news.com
[Music]
love Fox News click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the FoxNews rundown
playlist for the latest episodes